all right let's have a conversation
about economics here one of the stories
that Donald Trump has been telling us is
that the economy would be way better off
if the Federal Reserve would sort of
help him out with a federal funds rate
decrease the way that they've helped
previous presidents and Donald Trump has
been talking about this for several
years now the truth is that both
increases and decreases to the federal
funds rate can help out a president in
different ways because the logic is that
when you cut the federal funds rate it
makes it cheaper for banks to borrow
money which stimulates economic activity
which will then boost the stock market
but it also increases increasingly
signals when you do an increase I guess
is what I'm trying to say it signals
that the Fed sees the economy as strong
enough to tolerate an increase which can
also be liked by traders so there are
some economic reasons why it is said or
at least historically has been said that
decreases to the federal funds rate
stimulate certain types of economic
spending but at the same time increases
in the federal funds rate are meant to
signal strength by the Fed in their
opinion of the economy which can get
people also buying up stocks and running
up the price of the stock market so the
point is either way there is a mechanism
for which a federal funds rate move can
help the economy in the sort of
superficial ways that presidents pay
attention to so in any case Donald Trump
finally got himself a federal funds rate
decrease on August 1st and stocks
crashed looking at the Dow Jones you'll
see that upon the feds announcement of
the rate cut stocks were down about 3%
at the time of this filming today
intraday the Dow is down almost 600
additional points and there are three
things that I want to talk about here
Trump's response to this rate cuts more
generally as mechanisms for influencing
the economy and then what is really the
most important thing here which is
Donald Trump's tariffs so let's start
with the first issue Donald Trump after
begging for rate cuts and getting one
ended not boosting stocks and in fact
coinciding with the decrease came out
and said well okay the
reason that this rate cut didn't work
the way I expected was while the Fed did
do a rate cut they didn't do a bigger
rate cut which is what I really wanted
and they also didn't pair the rate cut
with a statement that they're gonna
continue doing further cuts so they're
just not sending a clear enough signal
about how great the economy is and is
going to be so we don't really need to
talk much more about that it's Trump
logic which is also known as anti logic
I mean it truly makes no sense
whatsoever and it is one of these things
of Donald Trump post facto coming up
with rationalizations that nothing
beyond a five-year-old or a hyper
partisan Republican would fall for so
then we get to more generally do rate
cuts actually stimulate the economy and
there's a really interesting article in
The New York Times which says that
lately no rate cuts don't really help
anymore in the modern economy the normal
sort of mechanism is you cut the federal
funds rate and this will lead to
Americans buying more durable goods like
cars and such it will drop interest
rates on mortgages so people will start
refinancing their homes they will lower
their payments and have more money freed
up to spend on other stuff so it's great
for the economy in that way there are
some other mechanisms but for the
consumer facing analysis that that's the
primary analysis but there's a different
modern economy now that we're in the
reality is the modern economy doesn't
really work this way people don't just
save save save and then when there's a
rate cut go out and do a ton of spending
spending has a much more sort of natural
cycle and then in addition to that
remember the bottom 50% of the economy
has stagnant wages they've had stagnant
wages for decades they just can't afford
it to do much more buying because the
Fed Funds rate went down 25 basis points
so primarily it is a method that ties
into big finance and for the run-up of
stock markets which again only benefit a
certain portion of the economy low rates
won't do much if people don't have money
so the long and short of it is that even
this reliance on rate cuts to jumpstart
economies or to prevent recessions
that's old economic thinking and of
course it's based on a neck
status quo that was never good for most
people anyway of indefinite growth as
the goal and such a such a sort of
divergence between the benefits to the
top 1% and 10% and 50% and almost
nothing for the bottom 50% so that's a
bigger conversation to be had but then
here's the real elephant in the room
completely missing from Trump getting
his rate cut and stocks crashing Trump
furious that a 25 basis point rate cut
didn't jump-start the stock market
consider that the same day that the rate
funds rate that the funds rate was cut
Trump announced two even more
destructive tariffs which are terrible
for the United States take a look at
this Trump on Twitter our
representatives have just returned from
China where they had constructive talks
having to do with the future trade deal
we thought we had a deal with China
three months ago but sadly China decided
to renegotiate the deal prior to signing
more recently China agreed to buy
agricultural products from the US and
large quantities but did not do so
additionally my friend my friend
President Xi said that he would stop the
sale of fentanyl to the United States
this never happened and Americans
continue to die trade talks are
continuing and during the talks the US
will start on September 1st putting a
small additional tariff of 10% on the
remaining 300 billion dollars of goods
and products coming from China into our
country this does not include the two
hundred and fifty billion dollars
already tariffed at 25 percent so the
entire conversation all along trump so
reliant on the federal funds rate which
increasingly does not generate the
economic reaction that it once used to
or was believed to Trump talking about
the rate decrease wasn't big enough the
messaging from the Fed wasn't strong
enough about how great the economy is
and that there will be subsequent rate
cuts that entire discussion was a farce
Trump wanted a rate cut and he got it
and stocks crashed well the problem is
not that the cut wasn't big enough the
New York Times explains the rate cuts in
general are less connected to immediate
stock market gains but nowhere in that
entire back-and-forth is the reality
that the same day that Trump announced
more tariffs that are terrible for
American company
and Americans at large the stock market
started to crash and is down as of right
now might be different by the time it
closes we're filming before the close of
the stock market today the Dow is down
an additional nearly 600 points as usual
Donald Trump's propagandizing combined
with a very poor understanding of basic
economics and the totally missing story
of the tariffs ends up with completely
wrong headlines related to what's
happening in our economy and of course
people fall for it and they say yes the
problem is what Trump says the problem
is not stagnant wages for 40 years
it's that liberal lefty biased Federal
Reserve that just won't give Donald
Trump a bigger rate cut Trump is the
victim as usual one of the things that
Trump has in common with many other
authoritarians regularly framing himself
as the victim I will be talking much
more about this actually Wednesday
evening I will be having a live stream
on Twitch at 6:30 p.m. Eastern Time we
will be talking about this and many
other economic issues follow me there
twitch.tv slash David Pakman and join me
Wednesday evening 6:30 p.m. Eastern